وضعوا سقف لاسعار الغاز يفرق الاوروبيين
اجتمعوا وزراء الطاقه في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لمناقشه مقترح قدمته مفوضيه
الاتحاد لكن هذا المقترح لم يرضي الراغبين
في وضع سقف للاسعار تقترح المفوضيه سقفا
يبدا العمل به اذا تجاوزت الاسعار 275
يورو لكل ميغاوات ساعي لمده اسبوعين واذا
كانت اعلى ب 85 يورو من سعر الغاز الطبيعي
المسالي في الاسواق العالميه قالت وزيره
المناخ البولنديه ان السقف الاسعار
الوارده في وثيقه المفوضيه يبدوك طرفه ولا
يرضي احدا فلماذا لا يرد مقترح المفوض
احدا داخل الاتحاد
الراغبون في وضع سقف للاسعار يقارنون
مقترحه 275 يورو مع الشروط التي رافقته
باسعار الغاز حاليا في اوروبا وهي نحو 124
لكل ميغاوات سعيد
ويقولون انه في هذه الحاله تبدو حظوظ
وضعها هذا السقف ده ايده جدا
وهي 15 دوله تقودها فرنسا واسبانيا
وايطاليا وبولندا محبطه من مقترح مفوضيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترى هذه الدول ان هذا
السقف ضروري لحمايه الاقتصاد والاسر من اي
زياده كبيره في الاسعار مثل ما حدث خلال
اغسطس خصوصا اذا كان فصل الشتاء باردا جدا
اما الدور الرافده لوضع سقف للاسعار
وتقودها المانيا فبعضها يتخوف من توقف
الامدادات الروسيه وبعضها الاخر يتخوفه من
ان يؤدي وضعه هذا السقف الى تغيير
المصدرين وجههم نحو اسواق تدفع اكثر خصوصا
في اسيا يؤثرها هذا الخلاف الاوروبي ايضا
على جهود مجموعه السبع لوضع حد اقصى لسعر
نفط روسيا المنقول بحرا في محاوله
لحرمانها من مداخيل ترى انها تمول بها
حربها على اوكرانيا تتفرج موسكو على هذا
الانقسام الاوروبي وتذكر بمواقفها قال
الكريملين ان روسيا لن توردن النفط والغاز
للدول الداعمه لسقف الاسعار وذكر الناطق
باسم الكربلاند متر بيسكوف باصدار الرئيس
بلادي من بوتين تعليمات بعدم تصدير النفط
والغاز للدول التي تضع سقفا للاسعار وقالت
خارجيه الروسيه ان محاولات الاتحاد
الاوروبي وضع سقفي للاسعار الغاز ستخلق
سابقه خطيره وتهدد بحدوده ركود عالمي يغلب
على موضوع سقف اسعى للغاز التابع
والاقتصادي لكن بعده السياسي لا يقل اهميه
فالاوروبيون يحاولون اظهار وحده الصف اما
بوتين وهذا الخلاف يظهر انهم لم يحققوا
ذلك بعد